3 oui oui oui on me dit on me dit que
l'invité est arrivé füle a comblé la
tour
[Musique]
toi on va parler de toi tu vois là la
gérance que je t'aurais répondu jacob
chose à dire je te jure un alors m6 la
web alors alors c'est la petite fille d
euros la capitale sa carte mais quand tu
prends la place et si vite tu dois
moment donné c'est génial d'imiter
patrick sébastien lord y en a qui
reliait dakar i fé mettetal est ouverte
rochambeau
on prend deux buts c'est le mythe de
l'éternelle rumeur s'est marié il y
avait un peu de de françois mitterrand m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les crocs pour apparaître deux
offres une offre visible et une offre
mystère ces offres sont des défis ou à
devoir relever tous les deux à toi de
choisir en premier si tu veux l'offre
vizille où l'offre mystère du salut au
kg au téléphone un camion shalalala
ouais jonathan je suis désolé mais je
sais pas si t'es au courant tu l'as vu
mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et si je joue comme ça j'avais pas la
bombe d'émission de 6 oui c'est moi
embrasser christian
avec nous avec nous venez tous on y va
voilà ce qui va se passer dans quelques
instants
l élégant a tout juste auréolé regarder
ça et franchement les deux la garde et
garder jusque-là les deux îles et où la
vie à peu près pareil
est-ce que j'ai gardé les d'autre à dire
waouh
on dirait du sarkozy fillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez bien confession d'un
cycle inventer
c'était gerra qui inventaient
confessions intimes est une production
d'une société qui s'appelle qu'issus de
dakar dont j'étais propriétaire et c'est
grâce à cette émission pour la première
fois j'ai monté ma boîte de prod donc
j'allais vraiment est généralement que
tout on est très fier d'avoir inventé
saluer
vous êtes très beau d'ailleurs je lui
dit alors en loge c'est vrai dit le
courbet a passé un cap au niveau du
physique vous n'avez pas dit tout à fait
comme ça mais j'ai dit que j'ai dit tout
elle est belle la courbette ce soir
akwaba c'est vrai
[Musique]
mais que la vie c'est u2
aucune coupe de champagne ou avère bas
la gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
alerte d'aucune et oui qu'est-ce qu'il a
lui bien j'étais au musée c'est de
quelqu'un sur le quai d orsay
oui eh bien mon tableau préféré de tous
les tableaux originaux et c'est pas lui
c'est julien coupat unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa croix
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
comme mes lunettes s'il te plaît tant
dans le titre du programme un peu rock'n
roll auquel on a pensé ses courbes et
vous pisse à la raie julien je voulais
te dire un truc je voulais te dire
vraiment tu vas je te dit tu vas
beaucoup me manquer parce que j'adorais
quand est autour de la table tu m'as
remplacer le vendredi c'était
exceptionnel et a fait des cartons
d'audience vraiment quand est arrivée
sur la chaîne je me rappelle très bien
jetable a appelé un samedi matin
c'est vrai je me rappelle qu'ils étaient
en vacances je sais plus où l'autre bout
du monde et je t'avais dit julien
vraiment je rêverais que tu viennes sur
s'est vite quand tu m'as dit oui j'étais
le plus heureux du monde parce que tu
sais que j'ai toujours été très fan de
toi notamment à la radio sur rtl parce
que tu t'étais juste avant jean pierre
et moi et c'est vrai que pour moi tu es
parti je te le dis vraiment des 3 4 et
je dis franchement meilleur animateur
que j'aie jamais rencontré vraiment que
je peux dire en impro tu peux tout faire
tu peux faire du magazine tu peux faire
d'univers this man tu peux faire du jeu
pour moi tu es vraiment un exemple je te
le dis et je voulais dire une dernière
chose on peut aussi se quitter sans se
déchirer exactement s'insulter fait dire
à se faire des procès simplement en
étant amis et je pense que je serai
toute la vie à cette famille et j'y
reviendrai j'espère très souvent
[Musique]